let me go next to our caller from the
five-30 area code who's calling today
from five three zero uh hi I'm Charlie
monix I am a huge fan hey Charlie what's
going on I have two questions if that's
okay
all right um so I personally think it's
hypocritical that the right wing has
this thing saying that political
correctness is it cancer because I
personally think the right wing has a
has a their own version of political
correctness don't you think absolutely
yeah we've talked about it before yeah I
mean I mean when you think about it um
that this is some youtuber this
conservative you to her um hunter
Avallone he's actually even talked about
him uh you know how Alex Jones got
banned from social media and some other
servers because they they violated Terms
of Service and a lot of people right
when were screaming about how the right
wing is getting censor on social media
and home travel and of all people came
out and said um no this is not really a
right wing left wing issue this happens
to everybody
um yeah I heard of him
I haven't heard of him no all right he's
a pretty interesting guy I think I I
think you should debate him sometime all
right
name is hunter Avalon yeah I got it I
have this Beckman Claire what's that I I
think I got the name yeah what was your
other question this is not necessarily
political is that okay that is okay yeah
okay um so in my area I'm a local solo
artist I was wondering if you wanted to
check out two of my singles that I have
released sure send them over to me by
email but I am gonna move on now because
we do have a lot of people who have
questions but you can email them to me
and I will gladly check them out